hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the whisper
challenge with Ryan Wade and Matt say hi
guys hey guys
ah back by popular demand everyone loved
this game we love to play so we went out
on Twitter and we got your tweets which
are weird and random you guys should
probably seek help seriously anyway so
we're gonna be playing the whisper
challenge if you don't know how it goes
I'm gonna be whispering to him he's got
music loud blasting in his ear holes and
so he's going to try to read my lips
from what I say I'm gonna be talking a
lot quieter than this and hopefully
we're gonna be able to pick up something
on the microphone cool huh okay oh no
I'm the team killer
[ __ ] okay alright
he's got it alright no we're okay oh
okay oh no I feel my juice oh no I feel
my juice oh oh no I feel my juice this
is what I oh my god okay
oh no I fingered my shoes oh hi you're
going somewhere
oh okay what what what did you say that
said oh no I felt like you steal my
Jimmy like juice yeah you should
oh no I [ __ ] hurts y ou know why you
said that listen I don't know look back
I didn't think he said that but okay the
real one was it's actually close
everyone got oh no but the rest was I'm
the team killing [ __ ]
oh never gonna get you
oh never gonna let you down Oh what is a
3-second say oh it's not is that ok I'll
do it again never gonna give you up
never gonna let you down
ok you got something well ok ok Wow
never get caught eating apples in front
of the clowns I oh right ok ok never get
caught eating apples in front of the
clowns
you got it you get ok he's got it ok
never eat the apples I happy clowns one
more time never eat the apple happy
clown okay Wade said never eat the
apples yes after 5:00 at my house
there's a lot of connotations that I
want to explore and it was never gonna
give you up never gonna let what do you
mean I can't bang my cousin what do you
mean I can't bang my cousin
I guess I don't know when you go to the
bank at night with kids when you go to
the pancake Hut you get cancer
where are your peacocks how about at the
store life as a rational explanation
that I guess I said when you go to the
pancake Hut pancake I kept saying
peacock you get cancer and I think I
said when you go to the bank at night
take kids are you guys ready
what do you mean I can't bang my cousin
okay I want to live your whip I want to
lick your women's cream okay oh my god
oh my god oh my god I wash my teeth with
women's creams I said did you say okay
what I said was I want to lick your
women's cream all right and then I said
I want to lick your whipped cream oh and
the original was I want to lick your
whipped cream can uh-oh
every pickle is in the jar
- chocolate every peacock choose Jewish
chocolate every Utah home as a Jewish
choco everybody choose Jew chocolate
oh you're surprisingly close to what
Matt had yeah boy he said like pika-pika
choose Jewish chocolate but you said
something completely different which
never been allergic to chocolate
yeah and the real one was every pickle
is in the jar I swear I live it your
lips I thought just like that one
thought you thought you read my lips
perfectly I thought I had 100% all right
purple monkey dishwasher my [ __ ] yeah
don't watch don't watch these people one
more time English
oops pimples don't wash poop peppers go
wash very closer what I said where oh I
said poop pimples don't wash and I said
burp my [ __ ] don't watch see when I say
this purple monkey dishwashers oh that
was completely innocent mark
send your tweets right for the whisper
challenge - hashtag
bag no I don't send your tweets right
for the whisper challenge hashtag banana
bag okay dick cheese Oh waits for cheese
what I don't know anything of what you
said ma'am dick cheese waits for cheese
at the bank take cheese watch for cheese
at the backdoor dick cheese what's for
dinner at the pet store gotta know
you're rich alone must send your tweets
right for the whisper challenge to
hashtag banana bed oh it was is to eat
chocolate penis poopy pants Shaun's
penis pooped its pants now I know your
[ __ ] you go one's penis who'd its pants
serious my song-song shut the penis
[ __ ] mess
8:35 original was chocolate puppy poopy
butts I you said I watched you all one
word I was sure thank you everybody for
watching the whisper challenge this has
been a travesty from start to finish but
you can watch the other families the
we've done in the past through the links
in the description below thanks Ryan way
to master being you check out their
tails kids with problems 1 minute 7 7 7
if you want see more god help me I don't
know let us know in the comments below
so thanks again everybody for watching
and as always we'll see you in the next
video bye bye